we're here to talk about comic-con what
to comic-con me a lot fun we wanted to
tell you what our favorites and this
favorites this did spray I think this
favorites is a word we're gonna stick
with it alright I think my number one
favorite what was it women in costumes
costumes were pretty near to God pretty
hot my god I don't know why attractive
women are swarming towards nerds but
please keep doing it my favorite would
have to be female Boba Fett that was
pretty hot i-i've never thought that
that Boba Fett could inspire an erection
female Kratos was hot oh Jesus Christ
that was that was bad in costume why am
i attract what is it about women
dressing as male characters that somehow
makes it even hotter I don't know but
here I saw Lady Deadpool wasn't showing
an inch of skin still Oh hot so hot
shown the face at all not even wearing
the mask wow I don't know why Desperate
Dan Lee was in the house Stan Lee was in
the house and you've gotta love Stan Lee
I'm gonna I'm gonna preamp this by
saying I love Stan Lee no matter what
Stan Lee's pretty austere King that
being said Stan Lee has gone senile and
people are willing I don't be he's gone
scene he's a little scene out and people
are still clapping no matter what he
says so I'm gonna data true I'm at a
panel and I'm watching and they're like
Stan Lee who's your favorite superhero
who's your favorite superhero you made
when I was growing up soda cost a nickel
and now I have a chair in my shadow
country and in everybody claps yes Ted
show the clip you show Waki gamer calm
we'll have the full talk that I recorded
cuz I was on the other side of the room
but there was a point where they're
talking about the game cuz it's the
Marvel games talk and Stanley just
chimes in I just want to say something
and it's not even relevant to the tough
but these guys are all really smart
these guys are the smartest people
excelsior and I want it just again I
love Stan we do love Stanley please
you're watching this we love you he got
a anything new people clap people
clapping we don't have that wouldn't if
we don't have that I can't go on say to
be like I like pudding and then ever
yeah Adams alive
he's fat oh okay next topic the
proliferation of cheap and we all
know how much Adam looks cheap seen so
much cheap stuff yes my first day there
I found a 75% off of trade back table
and I spent my paper bags trade
paperback table
I spent a hundred and fifty down and
then he comes back to the hotel he's
like dude you didn't tell me to leave my
wallet I I bought so many comic books
it's it's really sad and now I'm reading
them on the bus and everybody's looking
at me like I'm mentally deficient it's
awesome it is awesome it is awesome
everyone's now seeing what I already
knew reading ultimate x-men investing -
they give away a lot of free stuff lots
of rights DC was giving away copies
everything I got this one because I
thought it was funny video game nerds
driver and the best part is if you go
into the driver comic I'm like I got it
cuz I'm like ridiculous they're making a
comic about driving so let's let's look
at the story this is on page one you got
page page two and three there's two and
three are good and page four and five
and then up the comics over just have
character it was as bad as I was
expecting you know I'll say this when I
was playing the game driver I was like I
need to know more about this story of
this muffler yeah I'm like all I'm
seeing is the back of a car but what's
happening inside the car how many
transmissions has he burned out on the
way to this car a lot a lot I thought it
was cool I got to see a bunch of artists
while I was there I went and did the
sketchbook thing I'm a sketch book right
here show you a little stuff I'm not
gonna be able to talk much with it but
you can see here who's that Adam who's
that okay that would be Green Lantern it
is Green Lantern hey Libra Meho did a
really good Joker I actually have a
video of this hopefully I'll post it on
my kitchen or comedy but I corded him
doing this actually doing this sketch
and my favorite was one of the guys at
Pixar see that right here it's a his
character this beaver would you call it
yeah it's a beaver it's a beaver talking
to our 2d - who's projecting the beaver
can eat that's it for so oh that's
pretty cool let's film Captain America
though Oh Captain America is pretty
badass pretty good that's pretty
badass so we gotta find everything there
you go here's Captain America all these
for free just went around to the artists
table talk to them they're more than
willing to do this for me and this is
Dave Wilkins
it does many in Captain America so
lesson being next year at comic-con
bring a book full of blank pages for
these people to draw in they are
desperate for attention they are they
just want to meet the fans they really
the writers tend to get a lot of the
intention the artist artists artists are
just happy to have people over they do
do full commission a lot of them charge
to be like full-page colors but if
they're not busy they're more than happy
to do a sketch well I had a couple guys
just draw pictures of me I was standing
there like you want me to draw a picture
yeah drop one of me they look at me like
I'm in the pencil broke anyway they do
we're moving on moving on next thing I
want to talk about this is a dislike or
a diss favorite as we established at the
beginning Japanese companies giving
talks because there were a ton of PACOM
Namco whatever pick a especially game
company and the Japanese guy would be
always a good it was it all used to get
money for like 20 freakin minutes and
then the translator would be like we are
very proud to show you a dead cool
rising 1876 alpha yeah
Oh syndicates are gonna be sick and I so
get it together there will be
multiplayer I think it's a good thing
that and all the shit's on the slide
right behind them I don't need to say
anything you know it's I guess in a way
it's cool to have the creator of Megaman
there yeah until what you have to listen
to just hired somebody to tell me the
things that he won't have him come out
and say hi I'm the creator of Megaman
very happy to be here
this guy's gonna talk guys gonna talk
for me I'm just saying if I was in Japan
I wouldn't talk and the last thing this
was my thing the protest the Westboro
Baptist Church were they're trying to
claim that God hates all the comic-con
attendees because apparently we're all
gay yeah I don't understand why might be
but the rest of the people probably
weren't in vast majority I'm sure they
were gay people there I guarantee
they're really people there just like
they were straight people there but the
best part was the Comic Con attendees
changed a counter-protest and they're
maybe like less than 10 would you agree
baptist people yeah it was a small group
there must have been over a hundred
Comic Con attendees and the best were
the ones that had signs that like
Superman died for our Superman died
person that was a classic sign that was
a classic and I may be gay but I do love
Commander data just it didn't even make
sense but it's like alright dude
whatever that's it for us about Comic
Con check out our other videos out there
all over there here oh we're definitely
covering Adams face right now oh
including the cosplay footage full
cosplay footage enjoy
you